carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
reciban todos un cordial saludo desde
nuestros estudios en parís gracias por
acompañarnos en este recorrido por las
novedades del arte y de la cultura estos
son los temas que les hemos preparado
para hoy
en carrusel de las artes los invitamos a
explorar el grabado de monedas de la
mano del artista joaquín giménez creador
de numerosas monedas y medallas entre
ellas el árbol en el reverso de los
euros franceses
descubriremos los secretos del mítico
jabón de marsella un emblema y
patrimonio cultural con varios siglos de
historia
y fuimos al encuentro de carmen maría
vega artista francesa nacida en
guatemala y víctima del tráfico de niños
una historia que ella cuenta en sus
canciones
[Música]
comenzamos a este programa en el corazón
de parís con una visita a la institución
más antigua de francia la moneda de
parís donde se fabrican monedas medallas
y condecoraciones desde el siglo noveno
allí conocimos a joaquín giménez quien
acaba de ser nombrado grabador general
él ha diseñado numerosas monedas
francesas y europeas y joaquín nos
recibió en su taller
en francia el grabador general de
monedas dirige el servicio de creación
de monedas oficiales y conmemorativas
medallas y cuños de la moneda de parís
el título fue creado en 1547 por enrique
segundo de francia y hoy esa función
recae sobre el artista joaquín giménez
de con apoyo como padre para ser
grabador de monedas o de medallas no hay
una escuela específica es un oficio que
se aprende solamente en el seno de la
moneda parís y para ello hace falta toda
una vida en el pasado la fabricación del
artesanal desde el dibujo hasta la pieza
de metal hoy en día trabajamos con
computadoras y láser pero a pesar de eso
sigue siendo un trabajo muy manual se
comienza haciendo un dibujo que luego se
esculpe en un molde de yeso es decir que
nuestro principal instrumento de trabajo
es la mano el patrimonio de la máquina
joaquín giménez ha diseñado las monedas
de varios países y en francia su nombre
está en todos los monederos inscrito en
el árbol estrellado que adorna el
reverso de las piezas de uno y dos euros
francesas
en una moneda se cuenta una historia en
1999 diseñé este árbol para el euro
francés es un árbol con raíces cuyas
ramas y hojas se dirigen hacia las
estrellas de la unión europea es un
árbol europeo en francia el árbol es un
símbolo muy importante por ejemplo el
roble donde sandwich impartía justicia o
los árboles plantados durante la
revolución el árbol es protector un ser
viviente que no deja de crecer durante
toda su vida
las monedas y medallas grabadas por
joaquín están firmadas con su nombre y
llevan lo que se conoce en numismática
como una marca de seca ya que habrá
senegal es access postal de la trini
travel cada grabador general de la
moneda de parís tiene una marca de ceca
es un sello que se imprime en la moneda
y que garantiza que cada pieza salió de
nuestros talleres en una fecha precisa
mi marca es un cuadrado formado por dos
jotas mis iniciales y en el interior he
puesto la cabeza de un rinoceronte a
este animal se ha usado muchísimas veces
en la historia del arte de hecho
salvador dalí lo consideraba un símbolo
del saber lo coloqué en mi sello para
representar nuestro taller de grabado el
rinoceronte es un animal en vías de
extinción al igual que el grabado de
monedas
debemos seguir enseñando este oficio
artesanal porque es un patrimonio por
eso está en mis ojos si por saxo estando
el fbi como tomo munición
[Música]
vamos ahora al sur de francia para
explorar los secretos del bien ponderado
jabón de marsella un producto natural
con varios siglos de historia y que se
sigue fabricando aún hoy con una técnica
ancestral la jabonería más grande y
antigua de la ciudad nos abrió sus
puertas
[Música]
y el jabón verde y su olor particular
son todo un símbolo de la ciudad de
marsella un patrimonio histórico e
industrial contenido en un cubo
emblemático que se fabrica aún hoy según
el método ancestral
[Música]
y
el jabón de marsella está íntimamente
ligado a la historia de esta ciudad hay
evidencias de que se comenzó a fabricar
a partir del siglo 13 es decir que desde
hace 800 años se descubrió cómo hacer
este tipo de jabón poco a poco se fue
convirtiendo en una de las principales
industrias de la ciudad hubo una época
de oro entre los siglos 17 y 20 a
principios de 1900 había casi 100
fábricas de jabón en marsella
[Música]
lucas lo más importante no es el lugar
sino los ingredientes que se utilizan y
el proceso de fabricación del jabón de
marsella que es muy específico es una
que garantiza la calidad final del
producto y psychiatry final
[Música]
el jabón de marsella auténtico debe
contener al menos 72 por ciento de
aceites vegetales
exclusivamente agua sal y soda cáustica
el llamado procedimiento marsellés
consiste en cinco etapas que comienzan
hirviendo los aceites en calderas
gigantes una técnica que mitchell
bianconi aprendió de su padre hasta
convertirse él también en maestro
jamonero la sien copo en estas calderas
de 30 mililitros colocó 10 toneladas de
aceite
hoy en día usamos vapor para hervir los
aceites junto a la soda cáustica se
forma entonces una pasta que hay que
cocinar durante una semana para obtener
el jabón este proceso químico se llama
saponificación luego se hacen varios
lavados para separar el exceso de soda y
por último pasamos a la liquidación para
obtener una fase cristalina lisa ella
crea la face yo lo líquido
[Música]
si a pato aquí no hay botones todo es
manual hay que saber escuchar el hervor
observarlo olerlo con el oído la nariz y
los ojos se cuando la pasta está lista
es así que se llega a ser un buen
jabonero es algo que se aprende por amor
por eso es un arte ancestral se posaba
que se hace esto
[Música]
una vez fría la pasta de jabón es
moldeada en forma de barra cortada en
cubos y marcada en todas sus caras para
su comercialización
o
hoy en día el jabón de marsella ha
evolucionado hacia otros formatos y
productos para la casa o jabones
perfumados
en las familias francesas las abuelitas
compraban una barra de 4 kilos a veces
de mucho más y la cortaba en diferentes
pedazos para los diferentes usos de
casas de limpieza como del piso lavar la
ropa
para uno mismo ducharse lavarse y con el
tiempo pasó la barra a un cubo de este
tamaño este es el auténtico jabón de
marsella tenemos una gama perfumada con
el perfume más natural que hay en el
mercado que es hipoalergénico también
utilizando la lavanda la rosa
tenemos miel y almendra aromas
provenzales
y
[Música]
damos paso a nuestra crónica musical con
una talla olivares que fue al encuentro
de una artista francesa nacida en
guatemala su nombre es carmen maría vega
y ella nos confió su historia como
víctima de tráfico de niños algo que ha
contado en sus canciones y en un libro
la voz de carmen maría griega la
encontramos aquí en el distrito 10 de la
capital una voz de fuego que tiene mucho
mucho mucho que contar y se la
presentamos
[Música]
en esta canción niña de fuego primero la
experiencia de una ceremonia religiosa
maya que hice con rigoberta menchú en su
casa y sus dos guías espirituales en ese
momento le preguntaron al fuego cuál era
mi elemento y al parecer mi elemento es
el fuego
niña de fuego es un niño de ojo a eso y
se refiere también a un temperamento
latino y francés que me caracteriza
la canción la niña de fuego la fide efe
es una canción clave en el disco de
carmen maría vega llamado santamaría
escrito tras la búsqueda de su madre
biológica en guatemala una historia
increíble de tráfico de niños con europa
esto resulta ser un terremoto y en sus
canciones llega revela su gran secreto
una verdad sorprendente y un vuelco en
su vida
curvas con un gran día que el gran
secreto es como un castillo de naipes
que se derrumba yo creía que mi madre
era una activista que nos abandonó con
conciencia y por una causa así que de
alguna manera creí que me había salvado
la vida hay algo mágico entre comillas
al creer que mi madre era una mujer
feminista combativa la canción el gran
secreto es que descubrimos que en
américa latina y una trata de niños de
la cual yo fui víctima tras la guerra y
que duró muchísimo tiempo en guatemala
empezó durante los años 60 y pues para
mí descubrir todo esto a los 25 26 años
fue un terremoto yo tenía la necesidad
de entender pues ahora entiendo no me
esperaba encontrarme con esa verdad en
mis padres tampoco creían que todo era
legal y que si había demoras en algunos
expedientes pues era normal
[Música]
canción se llama el gran secreto y a
pesar de haber descubierto sus raíces su
madre biológica y con ella su idioma
materno
carmen marilla vega no ha podido superar
la barrera del castellano
[Música]
una especie de rechazo del espanyol no
lo puedo explicar pero es como si
tuviera una pequeña caja en mi cerebro
que dijera que no y todavía hoy para mí
es absolutamente complicado hablar en
español no es nada fácil no hay rechazo
a mi cultura pero ahí el rechazo a la
ipad
[Música]
carmen maría vega y la historia de su
vida artística e íntima revela un
problema internacional el de los bebés
robados y vendidos
si escuchas y también se lee en su libro
autobiográfico el canto de la cabra lo
son
[Música]
el canto de la cabra es donde busca hace
referencia a tus cosas a la tragedia
griega pero también es un personaje
recurrente que está en mi libro es el
nombre de la persona que dirigía la
asociación de nuestras adopciones
ilegales
[Música]
muchas gracias carmen maría por la vista
me ayuda carece de desgracias
[Música]
gracias natal olivares y vamos a
despedir este programa con una canción
de carmen maría vega agridulce gracias
por permitirnos estar en sus hogares
cuídense mucho y hasta la próxima agua
[Música]